desde personajes que puedes reconocer
hasta algunos que tal vez no los fans
del cosplay están más animados que nunca
para la primera cómic con a gran escala
en tres años no hay nada como esto en el
mundo así que me siento como un niño en
una tienda de caramelos era una especie
de cosa indefinida estaba pensando que
nunca íbamos a tener con mí con de nuevo
así que estoy realmente emocionada de
estar aquí si las dos últimas ediciones
del evento se celebraron en línea debido
al cob y 19 y hubo una asistencia
limitada en un evento reducido en san
diego el pasado noviembre pero se espera
que la asistencia de este año iguale los
niveles anteriores al surgimiento de la
pandemia con más de 130.000 aficionados
todos están obligados a mostrar una
prueba de vacunación contra el cubrir
una prueba negativa y a llevar tapabocas
además de cualquier otra máscara que
puedan tener me encanta es agradable
estar de vuelta era una tradición que
tenía y luego llevé a mi mujer en
nuestra primera cita a la comic-con así
que es algo muy especial para nosotros y
en cuanto mi hijo tenga la edad
suficiente lo llevaré también los
estudios de entretenimiento están
presentando una amplia gama de nuevos
contenidos pero los titulares de la
semana van a estar dominados por enormes
cerillas de fantasía que llegarán a las
pantallas de televisión próximamente el
señor de los anillos' los anillos del
poder llamarás un prime y un nuevo
spin-off de juego de tronos de hb o
llamado la casa del dragón
desarrolla